en 1750 en france le roi louis xiii est
tellement malade qui doit se baigner
dans du sang d'enfants
fraîchement assassiné c'est faux c'est
pas vrai pari 1750 de plus en plus de
mendiants et de vagabond entre dans la
capitale la police trouve qu'il y en un
trou et plus encore le roi français
louis 15 trouve que sa capitale est
inondée par la pauvreté 1900 est assez
et demande à son lieutenant général de
police de faire le ménage
ce qui va faire la police on va
commencer à enlever les mendiants les
vagabonds pour les emmener sur des
galères ou encore leur payer un voyage
dans les colonies au mississippi parce
qu'il faut nettoyer la capitale ils vont
enlever
certes le mendiant les vagabonds mais
bientôt aussi les enfants les enfants
d'artisans de marchand est là pour la
population parisienne sans nez trop
c'est une injustice et bientôt une
rumeur qui commence à essaimer partout
dans la capitale
une rumeur selon laquelle le roi louis
15 serait tellement malade de sa vie de
débauche et qu'il doit prendre un bain
tous les jours dans du sang d'enfants et
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle on
enlèverait ses enfants les gens y
croient dur comme fer
et quand ils voient arriver dans les
quartiers de paris les policiers qui
enlève les individus mais plus encore
les enfants le son est assez le 22 mai
1750 un exemple police du nom de l'abbé
arrête un enfant et la population
parisienne ce deal c'est fini on vole
arrêter ce gala
ils le prennent ils vont le lyncher mais
plus encore ils se rendent à la
résidence du lieutenant général de
police et veulent lui aussi lui faire
manger les pissenlits par la racine
mais c'est pas comme ça que ça va se
passer heureusement pour le lieutenant
général de police et le fuit mais la
révolte et au talent partout dans paris
on raconte cette histoire d'un roi
assoiffés de sang c'est la fin bientôt
de la révolte
mais l'image d'un roi qui justement se
baignent dans du sang d'enfants restent
et peu à peu ça désacralise la monarchie
parce qu'on se dit que le roi ne veut
plus le bien de son peuple
mais il veut se payer sur son